Many people
are wondering what Palestine will look like in 2024.
Israel has surrounded
the northern part of the Gaza Strip,
and it's unlikely that they will return that territory
given the way that Israel
has continuously absorbed Palestinian land over decades.
Therefore, it's likely that we will see a reduction of
one third of the Gaza Strip,
indicated by the purple region
in Palestine's present day map.
What's very concerning
is that a leaked document of Israel
showed that one of their potential plans
is to move all of the Palestinians in Gaza
to the Sinai region in Egypt.
Many people believe that this is what Israel
has always wanted to do with the Gaza Strip
and eventually
the West Bank.
Joe Biden has expressed his disapproval of this plan,
and so has Egypt.
But if Israel does it anyways,
then Palestine will look like mat B.
On Monday, November 6,
Benjamin Netanyahu
himself said that Israel plans to indefinitely
take overall security responsibility of Gaza
after the war.
Many people just see this as an excuse to steal land
and to make it look like mat B.
Any of these
outcomes happen without legal consequence for Israel.
Then it's likely that Israel will feel
empowered to do the same thing with the West Bank,
resulting in a map without Palestine.